god you look at you so forward thinking
we can't even enjoy the moment we just
we're waiting for next year i mean the
future is basically the future
present moment right
anyway yeah yes it is
okay let's let's you wanna you wanna
just go straight for the main course
or do you do do you wanna like do some
you wanna play some chaturanga
sure yeah that seems like the least
intimidating variance
okay because you can't really lose
quickly right
yeah yeah you can you can't i don't even
know
do you know the rules i know bishops are
less powerful
bishops and queens are less powerful
right i think i sent you a challenge by
the way
in the variance area oh i see okay
yeah so bishops move you can teleport
your bishops
uh through pawns two squares only two
squares so bishops only move two squares
why are the queen the queen and bishop
yeah they have no thieves
diagonally you gotta you do have to make
a move or else it'll abort okay
so pawns only go one square i knew that
yeah which is kind of sad
and then i can like do this
oh bishops can jump over things yeah
bishops but only three pieces
well i can't play bishop e2 here no only
bishop
and you can only play queenie two you
can't play
wait so queens move like kings
no queens actually are even more nerfed
they only move diagonally one square
oh that's so that's so sad but knights
and rocks are the same right
yeah rooks are the most powerful pieces
okay i think i understand
i don't even i'm trying to understand my
strategy
um let's play this move yesterday
i'm gonna go uh here okay
oh they fixed the bug you can right
click now without
oh without prompting the right click
yeah
i i was suffering from that in the fog
of war video
because i really wanted to draw arrows
oh this is so great and you see here you
could draw arrows anywhere any square to
any square
amazing can you draw different color
arrows no not yet
we'll get there well kudos to the
developers for being
responsive to this
all right i've no i i wanted to
encounter my bishop but i realized
like to get to g2 that takes a long time
like the bishops can't really
triangulate in the same way
there's also no there's no castling oh
no
okay
yeah i have like no strategy in this
game my strategy is just don't give away
knights and rooks for anything
like i guess that makes sense yeah
uh
trying to figure out like the piece
values
like rooks are probably more than five
or they're just five and everything else
is much lower
yeah i think rooks are on
uh in this mode i'm not sure
if they're five or more like for example
if i play knight g4 you can't take it
oh that's really sad but you're not your
knight is kind of
um
i was going to try and like insult your
knight but
i can't it's hard to i want to play f3
when i lose e3
so let's do it yeah but what's funny is
that playing night knight e3 like i'm
not actually threatening to take much
like i'm not threatening to take your
queen because that's a bad trait for me
oh that's true yeah at least that's what
i think that
i'm so the knight would be super
annoying there
are we playing three two yeah oh it's
three two okay
now i just want oh you're three first
things
can my queen not move wow that was a
good move
thanks that was a really good move
because i can't defend with my bishop
well you can defend other ways i know
but then i
get forked oh my oh my work is powerful
i wanna play f4 oh i have this move okay
yeah i was like what i i was looking at
every other move
apart from knight d2 if i don't have 92
i'm in big trouble
yeah but i think our nice
kind of cancel out yeah three two three
two but the thing is then you end up
getting into time trouble so
yeah and inevitably we're gonna have a
time scramble
at some point okay
okay control the center
that's yeah
okay
oh i'm just moving that knight around a
lot
g5 let's go
oh i forgot you can move back i thought
i thought i trapped your bishop
yeah it's pretty stupid oh man
this is so mind-bending okay let's play
a triangle setup
to me this this one is like interesting
but i wouldn't say it's the most
it's it's kind of going to be a slow
game
because imagine like it's going to go
kind of deep into the end game
because we like d5 would normally attack
a lot of things but you're not
not attacking anything like nothing can
take anything right now
literally i don't think you can take any
piece and vice versa
someone someone in my chat when i was
playing this was talking about how
this is like the
iranian version of chaturanga
oh are there different versions yeah
like i didn't know that there was
interesting
i'm just realizing my time is very low
oh yeah wow
my pawn
i don't know what you're talking about
what one on e3
we're i know we're just we're just
learning the game so i don't want to
i don't want to jump on mistakes like i
feel like that's that's a that's a cop
out
but i feel like once you activate the
rook it's like a serious problem
can i add you time no
you don't you don't need to oh i won't
flag i don't think
oh that was a good move i'm not giving
you any mercy
that was a good move thank you oh an f6
rook g7 and my queen's not a queen so it
doesn't protect
i would have forgotten about that
man my pawn feels so slow having to move
to h3 it's so
funny oh no
can do this though yeah my move just
looked cool i don't actually think it
was very good
at first i thought you were guaranteed
to win the knight but forgot the bishop
can't take on f3
i wanna play queen a4 oh you can't even
take me
oh you had two points that's crazy i
know i know
whoops i thought i was trapping you
ah i can't pre-move here
you can it's it's like settings oh okay
oh yeah
to change it oh my god what a weird
position
yeah and rooks are so strong at some
point we're gonna go
back to normal chess i think yeah we
if the queens and bishops get traded and
the pawns move
oh my god i don't know i don't like it
i think what i'm doing is good but i
have
no idea
uh no
that's not even a thread
oh it's so trippy to think that queen
like the queen
is so weak oh my pawn oh no
chaturanga tactics
it's so crazy that the queen's not even
like hanging oh your bishop's not even
attacking my pawn
oh yeah i'm so good sorry i i didn't
practice my chaturang
tactical abilities
that's check yeah that's check check
uh but everything's defended right
i think oh my god you're right
everything is defended what is this end
game
i don't know you just gave me a oh i
gave you my bishop
queen doesn't defend no
the tides have turned
yeah uh i i don't like this
so this is like how does one even win
this end game now i don't know
i got to promote a pawn i think
that's not even a check i just realized
uh like
my queen can never move to a dark square
like queens are oh my god you're right
that's so sad so i'm safe on the light
swears
is that even a check this is too trippy
man um
uh oh your pawns
but my pawn is strong too oh but i'll
have to promote to a rook
no no you actually auto promote to a
queen
no way wait are you serious i think so
like i'm pretty sure oh no
uh this isn't good huh
oh this is crazy
oh wait but that's that's mate is it
wait what's meat
queen d6 is mate i gotta like get out of
here no it's not
queen's queens don't attack sideways oh
my god you're right
eric i don't i don't like this anymore i
don't
wait i have two queens but is that
enough to win
i don't think so it might be i just have
to like corral your
king and not trade i think
is this like the craziest game of
gosh
wow so i don't even want to trade i
don't
think i'm playing this for a win
this is wild
hmm
go eric all right one of our brains
is gonna stop functioning at some point
i know and i hope it's
it's your brain and not my brain i'm
pretty sure it's gonna be my brain
this is too trippy it is
there we go oh my gosh this is you you
are
like a endgame savant here i just gotta
go for a run this is what i gotta do
this is like the first game of our other
match wow
yeah that is yeah you're right
not a thread this end game is not
checkers had a baby
i guess i'm getting better at this ah
check uh-oh
ah ah
oh you could have taken that with the
king no
i just realized you totally could have
taken
oh you could have taken that too ah oh
wait oh my god no i can't
no that that my king was actually
protecting
this is this is wild
if at any point you're ready to just you
know knock it off no i just want to
torture you for
a little bit more okay that you are like
the nicest torturer
i'm very close to zoo vlogging you i
think
i also how do i break through
can i bishop ever move to d4
how does my bishop move to d4
because i can't triangulate
this is so frustrating
ah this is great i love it
okay just trying to confuse you
50 move no oh i'm so close to winning
we're so close to fighting did they have
the 50 move rule back then
did they maybe i don't know
when was that introduced
i don't know man i
that's my first ever game of chaturanga
i don't know if i want to do that again
it was kind of
even though i was on the better side i
felt like i was also getting tortured
that that felt like the world's longest
blood draw
i'll tell you that yeah i feel good 133
moves
i feel like that's probably standard for
this sort of game to go
over 100 moves yeah it's so it's so
difficult hardwiring your brain to just
i wonder what we both missed i have no
idea i
i don't understand oh actually so you
have a cool tactic
uh way back when
oh yeah i'll tell you the move number
uh tell me
i hope i don't forget it
um oh yeah so um
on move you you had it for several moves
too
okay so after you play knight d3 on move
32
so move 33 you can just take on b2 with
your rook
because my queen nor my bishop actually
defend
oh you're right it's like one of these
understandable blind spots
then you're like almost meeting me i saw
like kind of
afterwards oh you played like knight i
think after you played rookie 8 then i
realized oh b2 was hanging
and it was still like your knight could
still take on b2 as well yeah
wow
that was rough yeah that was
uh that was an intense game
let's do something more fun than
chaturanga